in his long legal fight this is another
significant step and a step closer to
extradition julian assange's wife said
it was a dark day for democracy
a lot of conflicting feelings
i feel
a lot of resolve that i'm you know i
have to get him out
he has to be free and also
disbelief because the home secretary's
decision is
incomprehensible really
his supporters say he is a protector of
free speech but others disagree
julian assange is wanted in america
after releasing millions of classified
government documents among the wikileaks
revelations footage of u.s troops firing
on and killing civilians during the iraq
war
washington says he broke the law and
endangered lives he sought asylum in
london's ecuadorian embassy for seven
years making occasional balcony
appearances
extradition without charge
is not something that we expect from the
rule of law in the united kingdom
he'd been arrested on rape allegations
from sweden charges that were later
dropped
but in 2019 he was evicted from the
embassy and jailed for jumping bail
since then he's been held in belmar high
security prison
a home office spokesperson said there
were no grounds to stop the extradition
order being signed they said uk courts
had concluded it would not breach his
human rights and that he would be
treated appropriately in the u.s
his lawyers say his health is
deteriorating and they will appeal the
decision
i think it's important that people
remember what this case is about these
were award-winning publications back in
2010 and 2011. julian assange has been
nominated for the nobel peace prize for
these very publications for which he's
he now faces life in prison in the
united states this is dangerous for
press freedom it's dangerous for joining
assange but it's dangerous for every
journalist in this country
his legal team have two weeks to appeal
if it fails they'll try the european
court of human rights but as each stage
passes the options narrow for now though
the fight seems far from over laura
bundock sky news